Many adults may not know that simply being over 50 puts them at increased risk for shingles. Help prevent shingles in patients over 50 with shingricks. Shingricks is indicated for the prevention of herpes zoster, HZ, or shingles in adults 50 years of age or older. Consult the product monograph at gsk.ca slash shinricks slash PM for contra indications, warnings and precautions, adverse reactions, interactions, dosing and administration information. To request a product monograph or to report an adverse event, please call 1-800-387-7374.
许多成年人可能不知道，仅仅是年过50岁就会增加患带状疱疹的风险。请使用Shingrix帮助50岁以上的患者预防带状疱疹。Shingrix适用于预防50岁或以上的成年人感染带状疱疹（HZ）。请查阅gsk.ca/shingrix/PM上的产品专论，了解禁忌症、警告和注意事项、不良反应、相互作用、剂量和给药信息。如需索取产品专论或报告不良事件，请致电1-800-387-7374。
Learn more at thinkshinricks.ca Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On March 2, 2011, a frail looking Steve Jobs took to the stage of an art centre in San Francisco. Dressed in his iconic black turtleneck sweater and jeans, the Apple CEO addressed a sea of cheering reporters to unveil Apple's newest creation,
欲了解更多信息，请访问thinkshingrix.ca。我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本剧集的节目说明。2011年3月2日，看起来有些虚弱的史蒂夫·乔布斯走上了旧金山艺术中心的舞台。这位苹果公司首席执行官身穿标志性的黑色高领毛衣和牛仔裤，向台下欢呼的记者们展示了苹果的最新作品，
the iPad 2. Nine days later, on March 11, crowds swarmed outside of Apple stores throughout the United States, with customers hoping to get their hands on the latest model iPad. It was no different at a Maryland store located on Bethesda Row. Nestled amongst exclusive boutiques and trendy restaurants, the Bethesda Apple Store did a roaring trade on the night of Friday, March 11. Employees were run off their feet selling the iPad 2, in addition to serving other customers doing a spot of late night shopping.
iPad 2。九天后的3月11日，美国各地的苹果专卖店外挤满了人群，顾客们都希望能买到最新款的iPad。位于贝塞斯达街（Bethesda Row）的一家马里兰州门店也不例外。贝塞斯达苹果专卖店坐落在高档精品店和时尚餐厅之间，在3月11日星期五的晚上生意火爆。员工们忙得不可开交，不仅要销售iPad 2，还要接待其他进行深夜购物的顾客。
After closing, a few Apple employees stayed back to get things in order. Just after 10pm, the manager on duty, Lara, not her real name, was tallying up receipts at one of the tills when she suddenly heard a series of strange banging sounds. Lara asked one of the two security guards on duty to help her identify the origin of the noise. Separately, they scoped out the two-story Apple building as the noises increased in volume and frequency. After a few minutes, Lara followed the sound and realised it was coming from behind the wall that Apple shared with the store next door. She walked over and put her ear up to the wall.
关门后，几名苹果员工留下来整理店面。晚上10点刚过，当班经理拉拉（化名）正在其中一个收银台清点收据时，突然听到了一连串奇怪的撞击声。拉拉请当班的两名保安中的一人帮她查明噪音的来源。他们分别在两层楼的苹果大楼内搜寻，而噪音的音量和频率却在不断增加。几分钟后，拉拉循声而去，发现声音来自苹果店与隔壁商店共用的那堵墙后。她走过去，把耳朵贴在墙上。
In addition to banging and thudding noises, Lara could also hear grunting and what sounded like something heavy being dragged. Just then, Lara heard a hysterical female voice emanating through the wall. She raced upstairs to retrieve her senior manager who followed her to listen. He could also hear a female, who'd now sounded as though she was gasping for breath. A scream then pierced the air. Lara asked if she should call the police, but her manager didn't think it was serious. To him, it sounded as though someone had just received bad news. He told Lara, quote, I think it's just drama. The security guard agreed, and the three of them went back to work.
除了撞击声和重击声，拉拉还能听到咕哝声，以及听起来像是重物被拖动的声音。就在这时，拉拉听到墙那边传来一个歇斯底里的女性声音。她冲上楼叫来她的高级经理，经理跟着她一起听。他也听到了一个女人的声音，听起来像是正在喘不过气来。接着，一声尖叫划破了空气。拉拉问是否应该报警，但她的经理认为情况并不严重。在他听来，这就像是有人刚收到了坏消息。他对拉拉说：“我想这只是演戏。”保安也表示同意，于是他们三人回去继续工作了。
Meanwhile, the banging and thudding noises continued next door, along with the occasional scream. Approximately nine minutes after Lara first heard the noise, the female voice yelled, God help me, please help me. Shortly after that, it went quiet. Nearly one hour later, just after 11pm, Lara was the last Apple employee to leave for the night. She locked the front door to the Apple building and went home, oblivious to what had unfolded in the yoga store next door. Friday, March 11, 2011, was a change of routine for Jaina Murray, who worked as a salesperson and supervisor
与此同时，隔壁的撞击声和重击声仍在继续，偶尔还伴随着尖叫声。在拉拉第一次听到噪音大约九分钟后，那个女声喊道：“上帝救救我，请救救我。”此后不久，那边就安静了下来。近一个小时后，晚上11点刚过，拉拉是最后一个离开的苹果员工。她锁上苹果大楼的前门回家了，对隔壁瑜伽店发生的事情一无所知。2011年3月11日星期五，对于在贝塞斯达露露乐蒙（Lululemon Athletica）瑜伽店担任销售员和主管的杰娜·默里（Jaina Murray）来说，是一个打破常规的日子。
at the Lulu Lemon Athletica yoga store in Bethesda. The 30-year-old didn't usually work Fridays, but she'd agreed to swap shifts with a co-worker. Given the release of the iPad 2 at the Apple store next door, Jaina knew it would be a busy evening with extra foot traffic passing by. But she was only too happy to help. Jaina had been at the yoga store for two years and loved working there. The muscular five-foot-five-inch tall Jaina could be seen doing cartwheels and dancing with customers during quieter shifts, bringing with her a sense of energy and joy wherever she went. Jaina arrived at the Lulu Lemon store two hours early to catch up on some personal work. She took a seat in the back of the store, opened her laptop, and put on some music.
这位30岁的女性通常不在周五工作，但她同意与同事换班。考虑到隔壁苹果店发布iPad 2，杰娜知道这将是一个繁忙的夜晚，会有额外的人流经过。但她非常乐意帮忙。杰娜在瑜伽店工作了两年，非常热爱这份工作。在店里不忙的时候，可以看到身高五英尺五英寸、身材健美的杰娜在顾客面前翻跟头和跳舞，无论走到哪里，她都带来一种活力和快乐。杰娜提前两个小时到达露露乐蒙店处理一些个人事务。她在店后方找了个座位，打开笔记本电脑，放了一些音乐。
Her boyfriend, who lived in Seattle, was coming to visit her the following weekend, and Jaina wanted to make sure all her university coursework was up to date. Intelligent and determined, Jaina was completing her thesis to graduate with a master's degree in business administration and communication. Jaina was so impressed by Lulu Lemon's business model and philosophy that she jumped at the chance to use the company as the basis of her thesis. This included writing a crisis communication plan that Lulu Lemon staff could implement in the event of an internal emergency. The staff at the Lulu Lemon headquarters in Vancouver, Canada were thoroughly impressed with her plan. Once Jaina graduated, she hoped to move to Seattle
她住在西雅图的男友下周末要来看她，杰娜想确保她所有的大学课程作业都已完成。杰娜聪明且坚定，她正在完成硕士论文，以获得工商管理和传播学硕士学位。杰娜对露露乐蒙的商业模式和理念印象深刻，因此她抓住机会，将该公司作为她论文的基础。这包括编写一份危机沟通计划，供露露乐蒙员工在发生内部紧急情况时实施。加拿大温哥华露露乐蒙总部的员工对她的计划印象非常深刻。杰娜毕业后，希望搬到西雅图
with her boyfriend and then score a job at Lulu Lemon headquarters. As Jaina worked on her laptop, she was interrupted by her co-worker, who presented her with a bottle of wine as a token of appreciation for swapping shifts. Jaina happily chatted to her and some of the other employees on duty. Exuding a positive attitude that afforded her many friends wherever she went, Jaina lived life to the fullest. It was this mindset that made her the perfect employee for Lulu Lemon. She abided by one of the popular motivational quotes often seen advertised throughout Lulu Lemon stores, to live every day as if it was your last. 28-year-old Brittany Norwood was also having a lovely Friday. She spent the morning at a yoga
与男友团聚，然后在露露乐蒙总部找一份工作。当杰娜在笔记本电脑上工作时，她的同事打断了她，送给她一瓶酒，以感谢她换班。杰娜开心地与她以及其他当班员工聊天。杰娜散发着积极的态度，无论走到哪里都能结交许多朋友，她活出了最精彩的人生。正是这种心态使她成为露露乐蒙的完美员工。她遵循着露露乐蒙商店里经常张贴的一句流行励志名言：要把每一天都当作最后一天来过。28岁的布列塔尼·诺伍德（Brittany Norwood）也度过了一个愉快的周五。她早上参加了瑜伽
class before meeting a friend for lunch. Afterwards, she and her friend got their nails done, and Brittany then rushed to Lulu Lemon, making it just on time to start her 3pm shift. Brittany had only been at the Bethesda location for a few weeks, having transferred from another Lulu Lemon store, but so far she was enjoying it. Described as having a wide smile, welcoming nature and good sense of humour, she was quick to make friends. Like Jaina, Brittany was also a determined woman. She had previously managed VIP guests at a local intercontinental hotel, but had taken a considerable pay cut for the opportunity to work for Lulu Lemon. Her goal was to use the yoga store as a stepping stone to her dream career of becoming a personal
课，然后和朋友共进午餐。之后，她和朋友去做了美甲，然后布列塔尼匆忙赶往露露乐蒙，刚好赶上开始下午3点的班次。布列塔尼在贝塞斯达店工作才几周，是从另一家露露乐蒙店调过来的，但到目前为止她很喜欢这里。她被描述为笑容灿烂、性格热情、幽默感强，很快就交到了朋友。和杰娜一样，布列塔尼也是一个意志坚定的女性。她曾管理过当地一家洲际酒店的贵宾，但为了有机会在露露乐蒙工作，她接受了相当大的减薪。她的目标是将这家瑜伽店作为跳板，实现她成为私人
trainer and opening her own gym. As Brittany arrived at work that Friday, she was closer to realising her dream than ever before, having secured a job interview at the local gym the following week. Friday nights were typically busy for the Lulu Lemon store, and three salespeople were usually rostered on. However, one employee had called in sick, and nobody was available to cover for her, leaving Jaina and Brittany to hold down the fort on their own. They didn't mind, as they felt confident they could handle the workload. As the queue of people waiting to enter the Apple store next door increased, it remained busy at the yoga store. The line at Apple was still out the door when Lulu Lemon closed at 9pm.
教练并开设自己健身房的梦想职业。当布列塔尼那个周五到达工作岗位时，她比以往任何时候都更接近实现自己的梦想，因为她已经获得了下周在当地健身房的面试机会。周五晚上通常是露露乐蒙店最忙的时候，通常会安排三名销售人员。然而，一名员工请了病假，没有人能替她，这让杰娜和布列塔尼不得不独自撑起店面。她们并不介意，因为她们相信自己能应付工作量。随着隔壁苹果店排队等待进入的人群增加，瑜伽店也一直很忙。当露露乐蒙在晚上9点关门时，苹果店的队伍仍然排到了门外。
Jaina and Brittany completed the closing protocol for the store. As the more senior of the two, Jaina then switched off the lights, set the alarm, and locked the door. At 9.45pm, the women said their goodbyes and went their separate ways. The next morning, Lulu Lemon's store manager and owner, Rachel, made her way to work at 8am. Neatly dressed in workout gear and orange running shoes, she sipped a coffee as she passed a few people waiting for the Apple store to open. When she reached the front door of Lulu Lemon, she was displeased to discover that it was unlocked. Rachel swore under her breath at Jaina for not locking up properly. However, as she stepped inside, it immediately became clear that something
杰娜和布列塔尼完成了商店的关门程序。作为两人中资历较深的一位，杰娜随后关掉了灯，设置了警报，并锁上了门。晚上9点45分，两人道别后各奔东西。第二天早上，露露乐蒙的店长兼店主瑞秋（Rachel）在早上8点赶到店里。她穿着整洁的运动装，脚蹬橙色跑鞋，一边喝着咖啡，一边经过几个等待苹果店开门的人。当她走到露露乐蒙的前门时，发现门没锁，这让她很不高兴。瑞秋低声咒骂杰娜没有锁好门。然而，当她走进店里时，立刻意识到发生了
terrible had happened. Merchandise and clothing was strewn throughout. Manikins were lying on the floor and a flat screen TV had crashed and shattered on the ground. Rachel sidestepped a display table that had been moved, and then stopped. A bloody shoe print appeared in front of her. Outside the store, a young man named Ryan sat on a public bench absent-mindedly scrolling through his phone. He had missed out on an iPad 2 the night before, and had arrived at the Apple store early to ensure he didn't go home empty-handed. Ryan looked up, as Rachel made a hasty exit out of Lulu Lemon on her phone to the police. She asked Ryan if he had seen anyone enter or leave Lulu
可怕的事情。商品和衣服散落一地。人体模型倒在地上，一台平板电视摔碎在地上。瑞秋绕过一张被移动过的展示桌，然后停了下来。一个带血的鞋印出现在她面前。店外，一个名叫瑞安（Ryan）的年轻人正心不在焉地坐在公共长椅上刷手机。他前一天晚上没买到iPad 2，所以早早来到苹果店，确保自己不会空手而归。瑞安抬起头，看到瑞秋正匆忙从露露乐蒙跑出来，一边打电话报警。她问瑞安是否看到有人在那天早上进入或离开露露
Lemon that morning. He hadn't, but volunteered to check inside the store while they waited for police to arrive. Ryan made his way past the clothing racks and to the change rooms, where the bloody shoe prints increased. Following their trail, he called out. There was no response. After walking through a half-door at the back of the store, Ryan came to another door that led to a rear hallway and emergency exit. A large pool of blood had seeped underneath the door. Ryan tried to push it open, but there was something heavy on the other side. Forcing it open just enough to stick his head through, Ryan discovered the body of a woman propped up against the door, laying face down on the blood-drenched ground. Blood was splattered
乐蒙。他没有看到，但主动提出在等待警察到达时检查店里。瑞安走过衣架，来到更衣室，那里的血迹鞋印越来越多。他顺着痕迹走去，大声呼喊。没有人回应。穿过店后方的一扇半开的门后，瑞安来到另一扇通往后走廊和紧急出口的门前。一大滩血从门下渗了出来。瑞安试图推开门，但门后有重物挡着。瑞安用力推开门，刚好能把头伸进去，他发现一具女尸靠在门上，面朝下躺在血泊中。鲜血溅在
high up the walls. A length of rope was tied around the woman's neck, and a red toolbox sat on her back, with multiple blood-soaked tools surrounding her body. Panicked, Ryan made his way back outside. On his way, he passed two staffed bathrooms that he hadn't noticed on his way in. A pair of legs protruded from one of the doorways, tightly bound at the ankles by zip ties. It was the body of another woman, lying on her back with her wrists bound above her head. She was covered in wounds to her face and upper body, with blood coating her clothes. The black yoga pants she was wearing had been ripped open at the crotch, and a large white rock the size of a baseball lay beside her in a pool of blood.
高高的墙上。一根绳子系在女人的脖子上，她的背上放着一个红色的工具箱，周围散落着许多沾满鲜血的工具。惊慌失措的瑞安跑回店外。在路上，他经过了两个他进来时没注意到的员工洗手间。其中一个门口伸出两条腿，脚踝被扎带紧紧绑住。那是另一具女尸，仰面躺着，手腕被绑在头顶上方。她的脸部和上半身布满伤口，衣服上沾满了血。她穿着的黑色瑜伽裤在裆部被撕开，旁边血泊中躺着一块棒球大小的白色石头。
Within minutes, two officers arrived and made their way to the rear hallway. Once they'd established that the perpetrator was no longer in the store, one of the officers assessed the woman lying in the back hallway. It was Jaina Murray. It appeared she had been deceased for some time. The officer then raced to the bathrooms, where Brittany Norwood lay on the floor. Her eyes were closed, but she was still breathing. The officer cut Brittany free from the zip tie restraints, and paramedics soon arrived to take her to a nearby hospital.
几分钟内，两名警察赶到并前往后走廊。在确定行凶者已不在店里后，其中一名警察评估了躺在后走廊的女人。那是杰娜·默里。看起来她已经死亡一段时间了。警察随后冲向洗手间，布列塔尼·诺伍德躺在地板上。她闭着眼睛，但还在呼吸。警察剪断了绑住布列塔尼的扎带，医护人员很快赶到，将她送往附近的医院。
Investigators from the Montgomery County Police Department began their inquiries. Heading the case were detectives Jim Drury and Dimitri Rooven. Signs of a struggle were evident throughout the store. The registers were open and receipts were scattered behind the counter. Three small safes had also been opened and their contents emptied, indicating that robbery had been a motive for the assault on the two women. Meanwhile, Brittany underwent emergency treatment and regained consciousness. She had sustained numerous lacerations to her stomach, chest and legs, and had shards of glass
蒙哥马利县警察局的调查人员开始了他们的调查。负责此案的是吉姆·德鲁里（Jim Drury）和迪米特里·鲁文（Dimitri Rooven）侦探。店里到处都有打斗的迹象。收银机开着，收据散落在柜台后面。三个小保险箱也被打开并清空了，这表明抢劫是袭击这两名女性的动机。与此同时，布列塔尼接受了紧急治疗并恢复了意识。她的腹部、胸部和腿部有多处撕裂伤，背部
lodged in her back. There was a large wound to her forehead, and her right hand was covered in defence wounds from fighting off her attacker. Still in shock and pain, she began to explain what had happened to her and Jaina the night before. The ordeal was so brutal that the officer who took down the statement couldn't believe what she was hearing. At 9.45pm, Jaina closed up the store and the women went their separate ways. As Brittany walked to the nearby subway, she realised she'd left her wallet behind. She didn't have keys to the store, so she called Jaina to explain the situation.
嵌有玻璃碎片。她的前额有一处大伤口，右手布满了与袭击者搏斗留下的防御性伤口。在惊吓和痛苦中，她开始解释前一天晚上她和杰娜发生了什么。这段经历太残酷了，以至于做笔录的警察都不敢相信自己所听到的。晚上9点45分，杰娜关上店门，两人各奔东西。当布列塔尼走到附近的地铁站时，她意识到自己把钱包落下了。她没有店里的钥匙，所以打电话给杰娜解释了情况。
Coincidentally, Jaina had also accidentally left her laptop behind, so she told Brittany she would meet her back at the store to retrieve their belongings. They both arrived at Lulu Lemon just after 10pm. Jaina opened the door and deactivated the security alarm, but Brittany couldn't find her wallet anywhere. The two women searched the rear of the store for about 10 minutes before giving up. Jaina gave Brittany her metro travel card so she could get home and promised she would look for the wallet again in the morning. Just then, they realised they'd forgotten to lock the front door behind them when they came inside.
巧合的是，杰娜也意外地落下了笔记本电脑，所以她告诉布列塔尼她会回店里和她会合，取回她们的物品。她们都在晚上10点刚过到达了露露乐蒙。杰娜打开门并关闭了安全警报，但布列塔尼怎么也找不到钱包。两名女性在店后方搜寻了大约10分钟后放弃了。杰娜把她的地铁卡给了布列塔尼，这样她就能回家，并承诺第二天早上会再找一遍钱包。就在这时，她们意识到进来时忘了锁前门。
A man dressed head-to-toe in black clothing, including gloves, a hoodie and a ski mask, snuck out from behind a clothing rack. He hit Jaina over the back of the head with a metal bar. Suddenly, another man clad in the same attire appeared from a different clothing rack and grabbed Brittany by the hair. He began cutting her with a sharp object, warning that he'd slit her throat if she said a word. The other man took Jaina to the rear hallway, while Brittany's attacker dragged her to the bathroom. He yelled racial slurs at Brittany and called her a quote, dirty slut. He threw her to the ground and slit open her yoga pants at the crotch.
一个从头到脚穿着黑色衣服、戴着手套、连帽衫和滑雪面罩的男人从衣架后面溜了出来。他用金属棒击中了杰娜的后脑勺。突然，另一个穿着同样装束的男人从另一个衣架后面出现，抓住了布列塔尼的头发。他开始用尖锐的物体割伤她，警告说如果她敢说一个字，就割断她的喉咙。另一个男人把杰娜带到后走廊，而布列塔尼的袭击者把她拖进了洗手间。他对着布列塔尼大喊种族歧视的脏话，称她为“肮脏的荡妇”。他把她摔在地上，撕开了她瑜伽裤的裆部。
Brittany sobbed as she recounted the brutal rape that followed, which included the use of a coat hanger from the store that had serrated edges to keep the garments in position. At one point, the attacker hit Brittany on the head with a hard object, presumably the large rock found by her body, causing her to drift in and out of consciousness while the assault continued. All of a sudden, Brittany's attacker demanded she be quiet. Brittany listened closely and could hear voices coming from the Apple store next door. She prayed that someone would intervene and rescue her, but nothing happened. When the voices died down, the masked man pulled Brittany to her feet and ordered her to open the
布列塔尼啜泣着讲述了随后发生的残酷强奸，其中包括使用店里一个带有锯齿边缘的衣架，该衣架原本是用来固定衣服的。在某一时刻，袭击者用硬物击中了布列塔尼的头部，推测是她尸体旁发现的那块大石头，导致她在袭击继续时陷入昏迷。突然，布列塔尼的袭击者要求她保持安静。布列塔尼仔细听，能听到隔壁苹果店传来的声音。她祈祷有人能介入并救她，但什么也没发生。当声音平息后，蒙面男子把布列塔尼拉起来，命令她打开
cash registers and safes. As she complied, Brittany could hear Jaina screaming from the rear of the store. Her screams became quieter and less frequent before stopping altogether. The next thing Brittany remembered was being stretched outside by a paramedic. Brittany recalled that both of the men were of medium build, but one was significantly taller than the other. Jaina's attacker was approximately six feet tall, while the man who assaulted Brittany was about five foot five and had no trouble overpowering her five foot three, one hundred and twenty pound frame. From their voices, she guessed they were young white American men, but their black attire had covered most of their features. Brittany blamed herself for the ordeal,
收银机和保险箱。当她照做时，布列塔尼能听到杰娜在店后方尖叫。她的尖叫声变得越来越小，频率越来越低，最后完全停止了。布列塔尼记得的下一件事是被医护人员抬到外面。布列塔尼回忆说，两名男子都是中等身材，但其中一人明显比另一人高。杰娜的袭击者身高约六英尺，而袭击布列塔尼的男人身高约五英尺五英寸，他毫不费力地制服了身高五英尺三英寸、体重120磅的她。从他们的声音判断，她猜测他们是年轻的白人美国男性，但他们的黑色装束遮住了大部分特征。布列塔尼为这次磨难自责，
believing it wouldn't have happened if she hadn't forgotten her wallet. After forty-eight painful minutes of recounting the night's events, she asked, Is my friend okay? Brittany's statement helped the crime scene investigators piece together a timeline of events. As Brittany's attacker forced her to open the registers and safes, both he and Brittany had trekked blood throughout the store. The size seven and a half new balance shoe prints belonged to Brittany, meaning the size fourteen Reebok sneakers belonged to her attacker.
认为如果不是她忘了钱包，这一切就不会发生。在痛苦地讲述了48分钟当晚的事件后，她问：“我的朋友还好吗？”布列塔尼的陈述帮助犯罪现场调查人员拼凑出了事件的时间线。当布列塔尼的袭击者强迫她打开收银机和保险箱时，他和布列塔尼在店里到处留下了血迹。七码半的新百伦（New Balance）鞋印属于布列塔尼，这意味着十四码的锐步（Reebok）运动鞋属于她的袭击者。
Authorities believed that the attackers had watched the two women go back into Lulu Lemon from afar, and seeing an opportunity to burglarize the store had followed them inside seconds after they entered. Lulu Lemon offered a $125,000 reward for leads resulting in the conviction of the men responsible. The chief of police addressed reporters outside the store, giving a description of the two suspects and pleading for witnesses to come forward, adding, We only have one eyewitness, and she's been through a lot. Lara, the employee from Apple, was interviewed later that day. She broke down in tears when she discovered a woman had been murdered and another severely injured in an assault that she had largely dismissed. Jane's murder had occurred a mere eight feet from where the Apple
当局认为，袭击者从远处观察到两名女性回到露露乐蒙，看到抢劫商店的机会，便在她们进入后几秒钟尾随而入。露露乐蒙悬赏12.5万美元，奖励提供线索并最终将肇事者定罪的人。警察局长在店外向记者发表讲话，描述了两名嫌疑人的特征，并恳求目击者站出来，补充道：“我们只有一个目击者，她经历了很多。”苹果店的员工拉拉在当天晚些时候接受了采访。当她发现一名女性被谋杀，另一名女性在一次她基本没当回事的袭击中受重伤时，她崩溃大哭。杰娜被谋杀的地方距离苹果
employees had stood listening to her screaming. The Lulu Lemon store didn't have indoor surveillance, however there were CCTV cameras positioned outside the rear of the Apple store. These cameras captured the back car park shared by Apple and Lulu Lemon. As detectives began watching the previous night's recordings, nothing initially stood out. But at 11pm, just after the attack took place, two men entered the frame. They were both dressed entirely in black. The taller of the two wore a ski mask rolled up like a beanie and had a backpack slung over one shoulder. The shorter man was talking on a phone. The pair seemed in a hurry as they walked from the direction of Lulu Lemon and out
员工站着听她尖叫的地方仅八英尺远。露露乐蒙店没有室内监控，但在苹果店后方外侧安装了闭路电视摄像头。这些摄像头拍摄到了苹果和露露乐蒙共用的后停车场。当侦探们开始观看前一晚的录像时，起初并没有什么特别之处。但在晚上11点，袭击发生后不久，两名男子进入了画面。他们都穿着全黑衣服。两人中较高的一位戴着卷成无檐帽形状的滑雪面罩，肩上背着一个背包。较矮的男人正在打电话。两人似乎很匆忙，他们从露露乐蒙的方向走开，走出了
of view of the cameras. The detectives went frame by frame trying to get a clear picture of the man's faces, but it was too blurry. Regardless, they were certain these were the two suspects they were looking for. As detectives focused on identifying the two masked men, another lead came in. As detailed in the book The Yoga Store Murder by Dan Morse, the day after the attack, Jaina Murray's two-door silver Pontiac G5 was found in a car park three blocks from the Lulu Lemon store. Given that there was plenty of available parking much closer to the store when Jaina returned at 10pm, this was puzzling. An officer came forward to report that he'd been patrolling the car park at around 12.30
摄像头的视野。侦探们逐帧查看，试图看清男人的脸，但画面太模糊了。无论如何，他们确信这就是他们要找的两名嫌疑人。当侦探们专注于识别这两名蒙面男子时，另一条线索出现了。正如丹·莫尔斯（Dan Morse）在《瑜伽店谋杀案》（The Yoga Store Murder）一书中所述，袭击发生后的第二天，杰娜·默里的双门银色庞蒂亚克G5汽车在距离露露乐蒙店三个街区的一个停车场被发现。考虑到杰娜在晚上10点回来时，店附近有充足的停车位，这令人费解。一名警察站出来报告说，他在袭击当晚12点30分左右
on the night of the attack, 90 minutes after the two masked men were captured walking away from Lulu Lemon. As he drove past Jaina's Pontiac, he noticed the headlights were on and someone was sitting in the driver's seat. The officer considered pulling over to talk to the driver but changed his mind, thinking they'd likely just parked for a quick cigarette. The officer couldn't make out any details of the person in the driver's seat and continued on his way. However, two hours later, he returned to the car park to find the Pontiac in the same spot with its lights still on. This time, the officer couldn't see if there was anyone in the driver's seat and once again, he drove off. He patrolled the car park a third time an hour later to find the
巡逻该停车场，也就是两名蒙面男子被拍到离开露露乐蒙90分钟后。当他开车经过杰娜的庞蒂亚克时，他注意到车灯亮着，有人坐在驾驶座上。警察考虑过靠边停车与司机交谈，但改变了主意，认为他们可能只是停下来抽根烟。警察无法看清驾驶座上人的任何细节，继续前行。然而，两个小时后，他回到停车场，发现庞蒂亚克还在原地，车灯依然亮着。这一次，警察看不出驾驶座上是否有人，于是再次开车离开。一小时后，他第三次巡逻该停车场，发现
Pontiac vacant with its lights off. Detectives considered that Jaina's murderer may have been the person spotted in the driver's seat but they were at a loss to explain why. Word of the murder and assault of Jaina and Brittany spread around town and shocked the public. It was unlike anything seen in Bethesda, where local police were usually concerned with minor crimes in the affluent neighborhood. Women who would normally be more than comfortable walking alone along Bethesda Road began travelling in groups and arming themselves with pepper spray in case they were next to be targeted. A makeshift memorial adorned the sidewalk outside of Lululemon as distressed locals lay flowers and cards, one of which read,
庞蒂亚克空着，车灯也关了。侦探们认为杰娜的凶手可能是那个坐在驾驶座上的人，但他们无法解释原因。杰娜和布列塔尼被谋杀和袭击的消息在镇上传开，震惊了公众。这在贝塞斯达是前所未有的，当地警察通常只关心这个富裕社区的小罪行。平时在贝塞斯达路独自散步感到非常自在的女性开始结伴出行，并随身携带胡椒喷雾，以防成为下一个目标。露露乐蒙店外的人行道上摆满了临时纪念品，忧心忡忡的当地人放下鲜花和卡片，其中一张写着：
Two beautiful souls, one lost, one deeply hurt. The police tip line was a buzz with concerned locals phoning in their suspicions on who was responsible. Many could be dismissed almost immediately but there was one name that kept coming up over and over again, Keith Lockett. Keith was a 40 year old homeless man who was well known to those who lived in Bethesda. With the reputation for getting drunk and verbally abusive, many local women were terrified of him. Authorities questioned the manager of a local restaurant where Keith typically visited every day, only to find out that he hadn't come in on the Friday or Saturday when the attack took place. The manager of a nearby home west or
两个美丽的灵魂，一个逝去，一个深受伤害。警察举报热线充斥着忧心忡忡的当地人的电话，他们表达了对谁是肇事者的怀疑。许多线索几乎可以立即排除，但有一个名字反复出现：基思·洛克特（Keith Lockett）。基思是一名40岁的无家可归者，在贝塞斯达当地人尽皆知。他以酗酒和言语辱骂而闻名，许多当地女性对他感到恐惧。当局询问了基思每天通常光顾的一家当地餐厅的经理，结果发现他在袭击发生的周五或周六并没有来过。附近一家家居店的经理
recalled seeing Keith walk past Lululemon on the Friday of the attack. He'd had a backpack over his shoulder, which struck the manager as odd because he'd never seen Keith wearing a backpack. He'd been in the company of two other men whom the manager had never seen before. A former amateur boxer, Keith had a long rap sheet that included robbery, assault and battery. It didn't take long for officers to locate him. He was in a hospital out of town being treated for facial injuries, including a swollen eye. His clothes were covered in spots of dried blood. Detectives rushed to the hospital speculating that Jaina or Brittany may have injured him in self-defense. It made sense that he sought help from a hospital out of town to fly under the radar.
回忆说，在袭击发生的周五看到基思走过露露乐蒙。他肩上背着一个背包，这让经理觉得很奇怪，因为他从未见过基思背背包。他当时和另外两个经理从未见过的男人在一起。基思曾是一名业余拳击手，有很长的犯罪记录，包括抢劫、袭击和殴打。警察没花多久就找到了他。他当时正在城外的一家医院接受面部伤口治疗，包括一只肿胀的眼睛。他的衣服上沾满了干血点。侦探们冲进医院，推测杰娜或布列塔尼可能在自卫中伤了他。他寻求城外医院的帮助以避开视线，这说得通。
Keith's bloodied clothes were taken for DNA analysis, and once he was medically cleared, he was taken to the Montgomery County police station for questioning. He strongly denied having any involvement in the attack, but admitted being near the Lululemon store when it took place. As detailed in the book The Yogastore Murder, Keith Locker told the detectives that he had also been assaulted on the night of the attack, hence his facial injuries. He was assaulted by a, quote, short Spanish dude who hung out with a taller African-American man. From gossip on the streets, Keith knew the two men had recently peered up and were robbing stores in Bethesda. Keith then became emotional. He told detectives that he was standing across the road
基思沾满血迹的衣服被送去进行DNA分析，在医疗许可后，他被带到蒙哥马利县警察局接受审讯。他强烈否认参与了袭击，但承认袭击发生时他在露露乐蒙店附近。正如《瑜伽店谋杀案》一书中所述，基思·洛克特告诉侦探，他在袭击当晚也遭到了袭击，这就是他面部受伤的原因。他被一个“和一名较高的非裔美国人混在一起的矮个子西班牙裔家伙”袭击了。从街头传闻中，基思知道这两个人最近结伙在贝塞斯达抢劫商店。基思随后变得情绪激动。他告诉侦探，他当时正站在露露乐蒙
from Lululemon when, quote, the black dude and the Spanish dude robbed the lady and cut her. I seen it with my own eyes. Detectives didn't know what to make of Keith's statement. He was confused, sometimes incoherent, and told the officers that he suffered from schizoaffective disorder which required medication. Over the course of the interview, Keith's story changed multiple times, and he later claimed to have seen a gang of young teens riding skateboards out of the store. Workers at a homeless shelter who often supplied Keith with meals and a place to sleep conceded that he could be rude, but they didn't for one minute suspect him of committing the attack.
对面，“那个黑人伙计和西班牙裔伙计抢劫了那个女士并割伤了她。我亲眼所见。”侦探们不知道该如何看待基思的陈述。他很困惑，有时语无伦次，并告诉警察他患有分裂情感性障碍，需要服药。在审讯过程中，基思的故事多次改变，他后来声称看到一群骑滑板的年轻少年从店里出来。经常为基思提供食物和睡觉地方的收容所工作人员承认他可能很粗鲁，但他们一分钟也没有怀疑过他会实施这次袭击。
The blood on Keith's clothes was determined to be his own. Furthermore, none of his DNA was found at the Lululemon crime scene. With no physical evidence linking Keith to the attack, he was ruled out as a suspect. Meanwhile, the medical examiner working on Jaina's autopsy assumed that she'd been a victim of a motor vehicle or bicycle accident, given that her face and scalp were covered in so many bruises, lacerations and wounds. Jaina's face was so disfigured by various injuries that her features were unrecognizable. Lacerations on her face continued to her torso and back, and ranged in size from nearly pinprick, to four inches.
基思衣服上的血迹被确定是他自己的。此外，在露露乐蒙犯罪现场没有发现他的任何DNA。由于没有将基思与袭击联系起来的物证，他被排除了嫌疑。与此同时，负责杰娜尸检的法医推测她是一起机动车或自行车事故的受害者，因为她的脸部和头皮布满了如此多的淤青、撕裂伤和伤口。杰娜的脸因各种伤害而毁容，以至于她的特征无法辨认。脸部的撕裂伤延伸到她的躯干和背部，大小从近乎针孔到四英寸不等。
The crotch of Jaina's leggings had been slashed and an area of blood suggested to the medical examiner that like Brittany, Jaina had also been sexually assaulted. Fibers of rope found in Jaina's clenched hands matched the piece of rope tied around her neck, indicating that she had struggled to free herself. However, her death wasn't caused by strangulation, but from a one-inch stab wound sustained at the base of her skull. Presumably caused by a knife, the stabbing had severed her brainstem. In total, Jaina had sustained 13 skull fractures, and at least 331 separate injuries, of which 152 were to her head, and 105 were defensive wounds.
杰娜紧身裤的裆部被割开，血迹区域向法医暗示，像布列塔尼一样，杰娜也遭到了性侵犯。在杰娜紧握的手中发现的绳子纤维与系在她脖子上的绳子相符，表明她曾挣扎着试图解脱。然而，她的死因并非勒死，而是颅底受到一处一英寸的刺伤。推测是由刀造成的，刺伤切断了她的脑干。总的来说，杰娜遭受了13处颅骨骨折，以及至少331处不同的伤害，其中152处在头部，105处是防御性伤口。
Jaina was a chronic nail biter, and even though she had fought hard against her attacker, her nails were too short to have collected any DNA from her perpetrator. Jaina's wounds had been caused by various objects which had been taken from in the store, and many from the toolbox that had rested on her back. These items included a wrench, a foot-long metal bar, a metal display hook, a hammer, a box cutter, a Buddha statue, and an exacto knife, all of which were found around Jaina's body. By the evening of Monday, March 14, three days after the attack, Brittany had been released from hospital and was resting up at home. Her parents had flown in
杰娜有长期咬指甲的习惯，尽管她曾奋力反抗袭击者，但她的指甲太短，无法收集到肇事者的任何DNA。杰娜的伤口是由店里拿走的各种物体造成的，许多来自压在她背上的工具箱。这些物品包括一把扳手、一根一英尺长的金属棒、一个金属展示钩、一把锤子、一把美工刀、一尊佛像和一把手术刀，所有这些都在杰娜的尸体周围被发现。到3月14日星期一晚上，即袭击发生三天后，布列塔尼已出院并在家中休养。她的父母从
from across the country, and she was surrounded by her eight siblings whom she was extremely close to, and who dropped everything to support her. They were extremely worried about Brittany, as she'd become withdrawn and was hardly sleeping. Friends also rallied around her, sending her messages of love. Desperate for more information, detectives Drury and Reuven went to interview Brittany once more. Brittany struggled to talk, as she relived the violent assault again. She recalled how the two men were laughing as they carried out the burglary rape and murder, describing it as like a scene out of the violent video game Grand Theft Auto. Brittany paused.
全国各地飞来，她被八个兄弟姐妹包围着，她与他们关系非常亲密，他们放下一切来支持她。他们非常担心布列塔尼，因为她变得孤僻，几乎无法入睡。朋友们也团结在她身边，给她发送充满爱的消息。为了获得更多信息，德鲁里和鲁文侦探再次去采访布列塔尼。布列塔尼说话很吃力，因为她再次重温了那场暴力袭击。她回忆起两名男子在实施抢劫、强奸和谋杀时是如何大笑的，形容这就像暴力电子游戏《侠盗猎车手》（Grand Theft Auto）中的场景。布列塔尼停顿了一下。
There was something she had been keeping to herself out of sheer terror that the masked perpetrators would return. Bursting into tears, Brittany told the detectives that her attackers knew where she lived. Brittany explained that the two men were rifling through the contents of her bag when they found two separate utility bills showing her name and address. She was now terrified that they were going to pay her a visit. The detectives reassured the Norwoods that it was highly unlikely her perpetrators would return, but warned them to be on the lookout for any suspicious behavior from people in the street. As the detectives prepared to leave, Brittany's brother Chris asked to speak to them outside. He asked them why they thought the killers had
出于对蒙面肇事者会回来的极度恐惧，她一直隐瞒着一件事。布列塔尼泪流满面地告诉侦探，袭击者知道她住在哪里。布列塔尼解释说，两名男子在翻找她包里的东西时，发现了两张写有她姓名和地址的独立水电费账单。她现在非常害怕他们会找上门来。侦探们向诺伍德一家保证，肇事者回来的可能性极小，但警告他们要留意街上任何人的可疑行为。当侦探们准备离开时，布列塔尼的哥哥克里斯（Chris）要求在外面与他们谈谈。他问他们为什么认为凶手在杰娜被如此残忍地谋杀时
spared his sister when Jaina had been so savagely murdered. As detailed in the Yogastore murder, one of the detectives asked Chris what kind of person Brittany was. He paused before saying, my sister is a very secretive person. On the same day that Brittany was being interviewed at her home by detectives, Sergeant Craig Wittenberger entered the Lululemon store to continue his investigation. One detail continued to plague him. Why were only Brittany's shoe prints and one other pair found in the store when there were two masked men involved in the assault? Furthermore, why were there no bloody shoe prints outside the store, either at the front or back entrance?
放过了他的妹妹。正如《瑜伽店谋杀案》中所述，其中一名侦探问克里斯布列塔尼是什么样的人。他停顿了一下，然后说：“我妹妹是一个非常神秘的人。”就在布列塔尼在家中接受侦探采访的同一天，克雷格·威滕伯格（Craig Wittenberger）警长进入露露乐蒙店继续他的调查。一个细节一直困扰着他。当袭击涉及两名蒙面男子时，为什么店里只发现了布列塔尼的鞋印和另一双鞋印？此外，为什么店外，无论是前门还是后门入口，都没有带血的鞋印？
As Sergeant Wittenberger reexamined the front of the store, he noticed a table had been pushed up against the wall in all the commotion. When he slid it back, he found that the table had drawers underneath. Opening one, he pulled out a pair of shoes. Men's Reebok size 14 sneakers. Their tread was an exact match to the larger bloody shoe prints left in the store. The smaller shoe prints stopped abruptly in front of a sink at the back of the store, indicating that whoever wore them had removed them in an attempt to clean them. A strange pattern of scalloped blood marks then trailed from the sink back to the table draw, where the Reeboks were found. Analysis showed that the marks were from shoe laces that were
当威滕伯格警长重新检查店前部时，他注意到在混乱中有一张桌子被推到了墙边。当他把它推回去时，发现桌子下面有抽屉。打开一个抽屉，他拉出了一双鞋。男式锐步（Reebok）14码运动鞋。它们的鞋底花纹与店里留下的较大的带血鞋印完全吻合。较小的鞋印在店后方的一个水槽前戛然而止，表明穿鞋的人为了清洗它们而脱掉了鞋子。随后，一种奇怪的扇形血迹图案从水槽一直延伸到发现锐步鞋的桌子抽屉。分析显示，这些痕迹来自被稀释的血液弄湿的鞋带。每当那个人迈步时，
wet with diluted blood. Every time the person stepped, the ends of the shoe laces flicked on the floor and left a small mark. Detective Reuven questioned store manager Rachel about the Reeboks. She told him that the shoes were owned and kept at Lulu Lemon for their male customers to try on when buying pants. That way, any alterations that needed to be made to the length of the pants could be done in store. It was a major breakthrough. A forensic examiner concluded that the Reebok prints appeared to have been staged as the print patterns were inconsistent with normal movement. As detailed in Murder in the Yoga Store by Peter Ross Range, Detective Reuven considered this evidence and told his shocked colleagues, the footprints never left the store because the
鞋带末端就会在地上甩动并留下一个小痕迹。鲁文侦探询问店长瑞秋关于锐步鞋的事。她告诉他，这些鞋是露露乐蒙拥有并存放在店里，供男性顾客在购买裤子时试穿的。这样，裤子长度需要做的任何修改都可以在店里完成。这是一个重大突破。法医鉴定结论认为，锐步鞋印似乎是伪造的，因为印记图案与正常运动不符。正如彼得·罗斯·兰奇（Peter Ross Range）在《瑜伽店谋杀案》（Murder in the Yoga Store）中所述，鲁文侦探考虑了这一证据，并告诉他震惊的同事们：“脚印从未离开过店里，因为
killer never left the store. On Wednesday, March 17, six days after the murder, Brittany arrived at the police station having agreed to provide hair and fingerprint samples to help with the crime scene analysis. Brittany was taken to an interview room where she was told that the technicians collecting the samples had been delayed. While they waited, Detective Drury pressed Brittany to recall the night's events one more time. She retold the story nearly word for word, sobbing in parts. When she finished, Detective Drury asked if she had ever been in Jane's car before. Brittany replied no. The detectives knew she was lying. A forensic examination of Jane's Pontiac had revealed blood on the car's stick shift,
凶手从未离开过店里。”3月17日星期三，即谋杀案发生六天后，布列塔尼来到警察局，同意提供头发和指纹样本以协助犯罪现场分析。布列塔尼被带到一个审讯室，被告知收集样本的技术人员被耽搁了。在等待时，德鲁里侦探催促布列塔尼再次回忆当晚的事件。她几乎逐字逐句地重述了故事，中间几度啜泣。当她讲完后，德鲁里侦探问她是否以前坐过杰娜的车。布列塔尼回答没有。侦探们知道她在撒谎。对杰娜庞蒂亚克汽车的法医检查显示，车内的换挡杆、
the steering wheel and the inside of the door. DNA analysis showed the blood belonged to two people, Jane Amari and Brittany Norwood. A black Lululemon cap in the back seat had a bloodstain on the inside in the exact same position as the wound that Brittany had obtained to the centre of her forehead. DNA analysis confirmed it was Brittany's blood. Detectives wondered if Brittany could have been the person the patrol officer had seen sitting in the driver's seat after the attack. This speculation was not enough to place Brittany under arrest and so she was permitted to leave the station. The next day, Brittany's brother Chris called the detectives to let them know that his sister had something she wanted to get off her chest. Brittany soon arrived at the station
方向盘和车门内侧都有血迹。DNA分析显示，这些血迹属于两个人：杰娜·默里和布列塔尼·诺伍德。后座上的一顶黑色露露乐蒙帽子内侧有一个血迹，位置与布列塔尼前额中心受到的伤口完全吻合。DNA分析证实那是布列塔尼的血。侦探们想知道布列塔尼是否就是巡逻警察在袭击后看到坐在驾驶座上的人。这一推测不足以逮捕布列塔尼，因此她被允许离开警察局。第二天，布列塔尼的哥哥克里斯打电话给侦探，告知他们他的妹妹有话要说。布列塔尼很快到达了警察局。
with Chris and one of her sisters by her side. She told detectives there was something she had been keeping from them because she was frightened. She had in fact been in Jane's car on the night of her murder. Brittany claimed that midway through the assault, her attacker ordered her to move Jane's car which was parked outside the store. He didn't offer any explanation as to why, but as detailed in Murder in the Yoga Store, Brittany told detectives, quote, They said that if I was to pass anyone and open my mouth, I can consider myself dead, and that one of them would be watching me the entire time. I remember seeing a cop and I was just too scared to even flag him down.
在克里斯和她其中一个姐妹的陪伴下，她告诉侦探，因为害怕，她一直隐瞒了一些事情。事实上，在简遇害的那晚，她确实在简的车里。布列塔尼声称，在袭击过程中，袭击者命令她去挪动停在店外的简的车。他没有解释原因，但正如《瑜伽店谋杀案》中所述，布列塔尼告诉侦探：“他们说如果我遇到任何人并开口说话，我就死定了，而且他们中会有人一直盯着我。我记得当时看到一个警察，但我太害怕了，甚至不敢向他求助。”
Brittany said she parked the car a few blocks away and walked back to Lulu Lemon, passing pedestrians whilst covered in blood. Nobody noticed her injuries and she was too scared to ask anyone for help. Detectives Drury and Reuven were beyond dubious and figured that Brittany was trying to cover her tracks. They questioned why she didn't keep driving to safety. She explained that her attackers knew where she lived and she didn't want them to come back. No matter how hard the detectives tried, Brittany didn't budge from her story. Eventually, they gave up. They summoned Brittany's siblings into the interview room and said, Brittany killed Jaina.
布列塔尼说她把车停在几个街区外，然后走回露露乐檬（Lululemon），身上沾满了血，路人却没人注意到她的伤势，她也太害怕而不敢向任何人求助。德鲁里和鲁文侦探对此深表怀疑，认为布列塔尼是在掩盖罪行。他们质问她为什么不继续开车去安全的地方。她解释说袭击者知道她住哪里，她不想让他们找上门来。无论侦探们如何努力，布列塔尼始终坚持她的说法。最终，他们放弃了，把布列塔尼的兄弟姐妹叫进审讯室，说：“布列塔尼杀了简娜。”
Brittany's siblings listened in horror as Detective Drury detailed the extensive evidence that pointed to Brittany Norwood as the sole perpetrator of the assault that killed Jaina Murray. Any credibility to her story about two masked men was dispelled when the men captured on CCTV were identified as two kitchen hands in a nearby restaurant hurrying to work. The men were interviewed by detectives and ruled out as suspects immediately. It was purely coincidental that they happened to walk into the CCTV surveillance just after the attack had taken place. The week of forensic investigations into the store had provided ample evidence that pointed to Brittany's guilt, with the analysis of Jaina's car being the final piece of
布列塔尼的兄弟姐妹惊恐地听着德鲁里侦探详细列举了指向布列塔尼·诺伍德是杀害简娜·默里的唯一凶手的确凿证据。她关于两名蒙面男子的故事在监控录像中的两名男子被确认为附近餐厅两名匆忙赶去上班的厨房员工后，彻底不攻自破。侦探们询问了这两名男子，并立即排除了他们的嫌疑。他们恰好在袭击发生后走进监控范围纯属巧合。对商店进行的为期一周的法医调查提供了大量指向布列塔尼有罪的证据，而对简娜汽车的分析则是最后一块拼图。
the puzzle. Further interviews with the Apple employees who heard noises coming from the Lululemon store revealed they heard not one but two female voices on the night of the attack. They seemed to be arguing loudly before the screaming began. Just before one of the women could be heard yelling, God help me, another female voice was heard screaming, talk to me, don't do this, what's going on? From the very beginning, even Brittany's brother Chris had found it strange that Jaina had received such brutal injuries while Brittany had received superficial injuries that only required a short stay in hospital. Brittany tried to explain this to detectives saying that she had been spared
对听到露露乐檬店传出声音的苹果店员工进行的进一步采访显示，袭击当晚他们听到的不是一个，而是两个女性的声音。在尖叫声开始前，她们似乎在激烈争吵。就在其中一名女性喊出“上帝救救我”之前，另一个女性的声音尖叫道：“跟我说话，别这样，怎么了？”从一开始，甚至布列塔尼的哥哥克里斯就觉得很奇怪，简娜受了如此严重的伤，而布列塔尼却只受了些轻伤，只需在医院短暂停留。布列塔尼试图向侦探解释说，她之所以能逃过一劫，是因为她的强奸犯说她“做爱很有趣”。
from the brunt of the attack because her rapist said she was quote, fun to fuck. However, Brittany was examined by a nurse trained in treating victims of sexual assault. She found there were no clinical signs that Brittany had been raped, nor any physical injuries that would be expected following a rough sexual assault with the coat hanger. There were also no traces of semen found at the scene. Even though Jaina's pants had been slit, she hadn't been sexually assaulted either. The area of blood near her genitals was actually pulling from another wound on her body. In her original statement to detectives, Brittany claimed she had not been near Jaina's body
然而，一名受过性侵受害者护理培训的护士检查了布列塔尼，发现她没有任何临床迹象表明曾被强奸，也没有任何在遭受衣架粗暴性侵后应有的身体伤害。现场也没有发现精液痕迹。尽管简娜的裤子被割开了，但她也没有受到性侵。她生殖器附近的血迹实际上是从她身体另一处伤口流出的。在最初给侦探的陈述中，布列塔尼声称在两人分开后，她就没有靠近过简娜的尸体。
once the two had been separated. However, three days after the attack, Brittany provided another statement in which she claimed to have just remembered that her attacker had pushed her onto Jaina's bleeding body in an effort to psychologically torture her. Detectives believed Brittany had made up this story to explain why traces of her blood were found on Jaina's body. It was determined that all of the injuries Brittany sustained could have been self-inflicted. The lacerations to her upper back were only in positions that someone could reach with their own hands. They were all superficial and uniform in depth and appearance, indicating Brittany hadn't struggled when they were being inflicted. Brittany had
然而，在袭击发生三天后，布列塔尼提供了另一份陈述，声称她刚想起袭击者为了在心理上折磨她，曾把她推到简娜流血的尸体上。侦探们认为布列塔尼编造这个故事是为了解释为什么在简娜身上发现了她的血迹。经确定，布列塔尼所受的所有伤都可能是自残造成的。她上背部的裂伤位置只有自己伸手才能触及。这些伤口都很浅，深度和外观一致，表明布列塔尼在受伤时并没有挣扎。布列塔尼曾
claimed she'd been cut with various instruments while she had her clothes on. However, there were no lacerations in any of her clothing. When Brittany was found, her hands were ziplocked together high above her head. There was no reason for this as she could have lowered her arms any time. It seemed to detectives that she was putting on a show. Analysis of the zip ties used to restrain her wrists and ankles revealed bite marks and DNA where Brittany had used her teeth to secure them herself. A two-inch laceration between Brittany's right thumb and forefinger was originally labelled a defensive wound caused by a knife. However, analysis of the laceration indicated it had been caused by a knife slipping in Brittany's
声称她在穿着衣服时被各种工具割伤。然而，她的衣服上没有任何裂口。当布列塔尼被发现时，她的双手被扎带高高地绑在头顶。这完全没有必要，因为她随时可以放下手臂。在侦探看来，她是在演戏。对束缚她手腕和脚踝的扎带进行的分析显示，上面有牙印和DNA，说明是布列塔尼用牙齿自己固定的。布列塔尼右手拇指和食指之间的一处两英寸裂伤最初被标记为刀具造成的防御性伤口。然而，对裂伤的分析表明，这是布列塔尼在刺杀简娜时手滑导致的。
hand as she stabbed Jaina and lost her grip. Because the attack on Jaina had been so brutal and left her face so disfigured, it pointed to someone who knew Jaina and had immense feelings of hatred towards her, not a random burglar. It begged the ultimate question. Why would Brittany murder Jaina? Brittany Norwood came from a family of high achievers. She performed well in school and received good grades but it was on the soccer field that she really shone. Brittany received an athletic scholarship at Stony Brook University where she was named the team's most valuable player. With the dreams of becoming a social worker, Brittany was also studying sociology and psychology. But in 2004 she was asked to leave the university after multiple friends accused her
因为对简娜的袭击非常残忍，导致她面部毁容，这指向了一个认识简娜并对她怀有极大仇恨的人，而不是随机的入室盗窃者。这引出了终极问题：布列塔尼为什么要杀害简娜？布列塔尼·诺伍德来自一个高成就家庭。她在学校表现良好，成绩优异，但在足球场上她才真正大放异彩。布列塔尼获得了石溪大学的体育奖学金，并被评为队内最有价值球员。怀揣着成为社会工作者的梦想，布列塔尼还学习了社会学和心理学。但在2004年，在多名朋友指控她
of stealing from them. Brittany broke down and admitted to it. She promised not to do it again, however she didn't stay true to her word. She later stole $300 from one of her sisters' purses during a family gathering, although she wholeheartedly denied doing so. Although she had told family and friends she had graduated, Brittany left the university before completing her degree. She secured a job working at the Willard Intercontinental Hotel situated a stone's throw from the White House. Things were looking up for Brittany, she was well liked and quickly promoted, once winning the title of employee of the quarter. However, Brittany also had a secretive side. In 2007 she broke up with her boyfriend of 18 months.
偷窃后，她被要求离开大学。布列塔尼崩溃并承认了。她承诺不再犯，但并没有信守诺言。后来在一次家庭聚会上，她从其中一个姐妹的钱包里偷了300美元，尽管她极力否认。虽然她告诉家人和朋友她已经毕业，但布列塔尼在完成学位前就离开了大学。她在离白宫仅一步之遥的威拉德洲际酒店找到了一份工作。布列塔尼的情况有所好转，她很受欢迎并很快得到晋升，曾获得季度最佳员工称号。然而，布列塔尼也有隐秘的一面。2007年，她与交往18个月的男友分手。
The following year she broke into his house and stole various items including jewellery, blank checks and car keys. Brittany's ex filed a restraining order against her, claiming she had also been physically abusive towards him and he feared for his safety. Brittany violated the restraining order within two weeks and an arrest warrant was subsequently issued but never executed. Authorities were busy with more serious crimes and the warrant expired after a year. With the goal of becoming a personal trainer Brittany left her job at the hotel and started working at the Lululemon store in Georgetown DC. Shortly after a co-worker accused her of stealing money from the Tills. In January 2011 Brittany was fired after her boss accused her
第二年，她闯入他的房子，偷走了包括珠宝、空白支票和车钥匙在内的各种物品。布列塔尼的前男友对她申请了限制令，声称她也曾对他进行过身体虐待，他担心自己的安全。布列塔尼在两周内违反了限制令，随后签发了逮捕令但从未执行。当局忙于处理更严重的犯罪，逮捕令在一年后过期。为了成为一名私人教练，布列塔尼辞去了酒店的工作，开始在华盛顿特区乔治城的露露乐檬店工作。不久后，一名同事指控她从收银机里偷钱。2011年1月，布列塔尼在老板指控她
of abusing her store discount. Brittany disputed this and in the end management at Lululemon decided not to fire her. Instead she was transferred to the Bethesda store. As detailed in the book The Yoga Store Murder after meeting up with her future co-workers Brittany sent one of them a text message which read, you have such a solid team I know it'll be a great experience. Over the coming weeks several employees at the Bethesda store noticed that certain items were missing. When these employees confronted the store manager she checked the roster and noticed that Brittany had been working each time that something disappeared. Two days prior to the store attack at a weekly leadership meeting which included Jaina Murray the team huddled together and
滥用员工折扣后被解雇。布列塔尼对此提出异议，最终露露乐檬的管理层决定不解雇她，而是将她调到了贝塞斯达店。正如《瑜伽店谋杀案》一书中所述，在与未来的同事见面后，布列塔尼给其中一人发了一条短信，写道：“你们的团队非常稳固，我知道这将是一次很棒的经历。”在接下来的几周里，贝塞斯达店的几名员工注意到某些商品不见了。当这些员工质问店长时，她查看了排班表，发现每次东西丢失时布列塔尼都在上班。在袭击发生前两天，包括简娜·默里在内的一次每周领导会议上，团队聚在一起
discussed how they were going to catch Brittany in the act so she could be legitimately fired. They joked about setting up a nanny cam inside the store. In the end the team decided that the best course of action would be to announce to all staff the possibility that a thief was amongst them and then see what happened. Before their co-workers left on Friday March 11 Jaina commented I have to close with the thief tonight do you think I will catch her? Jaina and Brittany worked happily together that evening but when it came time to lock up Jaina asked to look inside Brittany's bag it was store policy to do so. When Brittany opened her bag Jaina spotted a pair of Lululemon yoga pants with tags attached
讨论如何当场抓住布列塔尼，以便能合法地解雇她。他们开玩笑说要在店里安装隐蔽摄像头。最终，团队决定最好的办法是向所有员工宣布他们中间可能存在小偷，然后看看会发生什么。在同事们周五（3月11日）离开之前，简娜评论道：“今晚我要和小偷一起关店，你们觉得我能抓住她吗？”那天晚上简娜和布列塔尼一起工作得很愉快，但到了关店时间，简娜要求查看布列塔尼的包，这是商店的规定。当布列塔尼打开包时，简娜发现了一双带有标签的露露乐檬瑜伽裤，
but no store receipt. Brittany denied stealing them claiming she had bought them earlier in the day. As the computer system had already been shut down for the night Jaina told Brittany not to worry they would sort it out later then they left the store. On her way to her car Jaina called the employee who Brittany claimed sold her the yoga pants. The employee denied doing so Jaina called her boss Rachel who told Jaina not to worry about it now that they had caught Brittany in the act Rachel planned to dismiss her the following day. Just as Jaina began driving home her phone rang it was Brittany who had lost her wallet and needed Jaina to let her into the store. As detailed in the murder in the yoga store
但没有商店收据。布列塔尼否认偷窃，声称她是当天早些时候买的。由于电脑系统已经关闭，简娜告诉布列塔尼不用担心，以后再处理，然后她们离开了商店。在去停车场的路上，简娜给布列塔尼声称卖给她瑜伽裤的员工打了电话。该员工否认了这一点。简娜给她的老板瑞秋打了电话，瑞秋告诉简娜现在不用担心，既然已经当场抓住了布列塔尼，瑞秋计划第二天解雇她。就在简娜开车回家时，电话响了，是布列塔尼，她说丢了钱包，需要简娜让她进店。正如《瑜伽店谋杀案》中所述，
after being let inside Brittany likely asked to Jaina what was going to happen now that she had been found with stolen merchandise. Although the details of the conversation aren't known their escalating voices could be overheard in the Apple store next door. Forensic analysis showed Brittany first attacked Jaina in the back store room by hitting her on the back of the head with a metal bar. Jaina attempted to fight back but the violent attack continued. The final blow was from a knife kept in the back room of the store. Jaina had parked her car in a no standing area right outside the store thinking she'd just be running in for a few minutes. Knowing that Jaina's car would draw attention there Brittany rummaged
在被放进去后，布列塔尼很可能问简娜，既然被发现有赃物，现在该怎么办。虽然谈话细节不得而知，但她们升级的声音在隔壁的苹果店可以听到。法医分析显示，布列塔尼首先在后储藏室用金属棒击打简娜的后脑勺，袭击了她。简娜试图反击，但暴力袭击仍在继续。最后一击来自店里后间存放的一把刀。简娜把车停在店外禁止停车的区域，以为只会进去几分钟。知道简娜的车会引起注意，布列塔尼翻找
through Jaina's bag until she found her keys. She drove Jaina's Pontiac to a parking lot three blocks away where she sat to think about what to do next. Had the patrol officer investigated when he drove past he would have caught Brittany covered in blood. Brittany returned to the store and stood in the huge amount of blood that had pulled around Jaina's body. She then walked bloody shoe prints around the cash registers and safes before replacing her shoes with the men's Reeboks kept in the store and repeating the process. Brittany then washed both pairs in the back sink. She put her new balance running shoes back on and walked the Reeboks back to the drawer in the table. As she walked her own shoelaces left little marks of diluted blood. Brittany then
简娜的包，直到找到她的钥匙。她把简娜的庞蒂亚克车开到了三个街区外的一个停车场，坐在那里思考下一步该做什么。如果巡逻警察开车经过时进行调查，他就会抓住浑身是血的布列塔尼。布列塔尼回到店里，站在简娜尸体周围汇聚的大量血泊中。她然后在收银机和保险柜周围走动，留下血脚印，随后换上店里存放的男式锐步鞋，重复了这个过程。布列塔尼然后在后水槽里清洗了两双鞋。她换回自己的新百伦跑鞋，把锐步鞋放回桌子的抽屉里。当她走动时，她自己的鞋带留下了稀释血迹的小痕迹。布列塔尼随后
threw clothes from the hangers and toppled over mannequins to make it appear as though a struggle had taken place. At some stage she slit the crotch of Jaina's pants to make it seem as though she had been sexually assaulted. With the scene complete Brittany then inflicted several cuts to her own body, cut open the crotch to her yoga pants, restrained her hands and feet and lay on the bathroom floor. All she had to do then was wait for someone to find her. Brittany's brother and sister sat in shock as Detective Drury listed the evidence pointing to Brittany's guilt. They did not believe she could unleash such a brutal assault resulting in murder over a pair of stolen yoga pants. Detective Drury was upset for the Norwood family as he considered them
把衣服从衣架上扔下来，推倒人体模型，制造出发生过挣扎的假象。在某个阶段，她割开了简娜裤子的裆部，让人觉得她受到了性侵。现场布置完成后，布列塔尼在自己身上割了几道伤口，割开自己瑜伽裤的裆部，束缚住手脚，躺在浴室地板上。她接下来要做的就是等待有人发现她。布列塔尼的兄弟姐妹震惊地坐着，听着德鲁里侦探列举指向布列塔尼有罪的证据。他们不相信她会因为一条偷来的瑜伽裤而发动如此残忍的袭击并导致谋杀。德鲁里侦探为诺伍德一家感到难过，因为他认为他们是
lovely and cooperative people. Brittany's father had even invited him to go fishing once the investigation was over. The detective himself struggled to come to terms with Brittany's guilt telling her family quote, I did not want to believe it at first. I did not want to believe it. On Friday March 18 one week to the day since the attack Brittany was arrested for first degree murder. The day of the arrest coincided with the Jaina's funeral. Over 200 people gathered to say goodbye to Jaina including the founder and CEO of Lululemon. As Jaina's parents drove to the chapel they received a call from detectives informing them they had made an arrest. They were horrified to learn the person who killed their daughter was Brittany Norwood. Following Brittany's arrest
可爱且配合的人。布列塔尼的父亲甚至在调查结束后邀请他去钓鱼。侦探本人也很难接受布列塔尼有罪的事实，他告诉她的家人：“起初我不想相信。我真的不想相信。”3月18日星期五，即袭击发生一周后，布列塔尼因一级谋杀罪被捕。逮捕当天恰逢简娜的葬礼。200多名亲友聚集在一起为简娜送行，其中包括露露乐檬的创始人和首席执行官。当简娜的父母开车去教堂时，他们接到了侦探的电话，通知他们已经逮捕了嫌疑人。得知杀害他们女儿的人是布列塔尼·诺伍德，他们感到非常震惊。布列塔尼被捕后，
the state prosecutor met with the Jaina's family to see if they would accept a plea deal instead of going to trial. The plea bargain entailed that Brittany would serve 15 years of her sentence and then become eligible for parole. Jaina's family refused to accept this and a trial date was announced. 10 days before the trial the judge dealt a blow to the prosecution. They would not be allowed to give evidence regarding the telephone conversations between Jaina and Rachel just prior to the murder in which Jaina told her boss she had caught Brittany stealing. Classified as hearsay this ruling was critical as it meant that the prosecution could not argue a motive for Jaina's murder. Brittany's trial began on October 24, 2011 in the Montgomery County
州检察官会见了简娜的家人，看他们是否愿意接受认罪协议而不是进行审判。认罪协议规定布列塔尼将服刑15年，然后有资格获得假释。简娜的家人拒绝接受，审判日期随即公布。审判前10天，法官对检方造成了打击。他们不被允许提供关于简娜和瑞秋在谋杀前不久的电话交谈的证据，在电话中简娜告诉老板她抓住了布列塔尼偷窃。由于被归类为传闻，这一裁决至关重要，这意味着检方无法为简娜的谋杀案辩论动机。布列塔尼的审判于2011年10月24日在蒙哥马利县
Circuit Court in Rockville, Maryland. Over 200 exhibits and 25 witnesses were called including including the Apple Store employees who recounted hearing Jaina's cries for help. The prosecutor conceded that Brittany had played her part very well. He admitted that had she discarded the men's Reebok shoes instead of returning them to the draw and left Jaina's car parked in its original location Brittany may have gotten away with murder. In his opening statement Brittany's defense attorney stunned the jury and onlookers when he cut straight to the point and admitted Brittany's guilt saying there was a horrific fight and during that fight Brittany Norwood lost it. Jaina was killed by Brittany.
巡回法院开始。传唤了200多件证物和25名证人，包括听到简娜求救声的苹果店员工。检察官承认布列塔尼演得非常好。他承认，如果她丢弃了男式锐步鞋而不是放回抽屉，并把简娜的车留在原位，布列塔尼可能就逃脱了谋杀罪。在开庭陈述中，布列塔尼的辩护律师直奔主题，承认了布列塔尼的罪行，震惊了陪审团和旁观者，他说：“发生了一场可怕的争斗，在那场争斗中，布列塔尼·诺伍德失去了理智。简娜是被布列塔尼杀害的。”
There was no point in maintaining her innocence. The evidence against her was too overwhelming. Rather Brittany was seeking to be convicted for second degree murder instead of first. On November 2, 2011 the jury deliberated for only 21 minutes before finding Brittany Norwood guilty for the first degree murder of Jaina Murray. As both families cried at the verdict Brittany remained still and silent showing no emotion. Less than 24 hours later Jaina's parents went shopping at the Bethesda Lululemon store that had since reopened following their daughter's murder. Her father David told CBS that there was an important reason for their visit. Saying, Nothing will start until we pass the first day of the new normal we're searching for,
坚持她的清白已毫无意义。针对她的证据太确凿了。相反，布列塔尼试图被判二级谋杀罪而不是一级。2011年11月2日，陪审团仅审议了21分钟，就裁定布列塔尼·诺伍德犯有一级谋杀简娜·默里罪。当两个家庭在判决结果出来时哭泣时，布列塔尼保持静止和沉默，没有表现出任何情绪。不到24小时后，简娜的父母去贝塞斯达的露露乐檬店购物，该店在他们女儿遇害后已经重新开业。她的父亲大卫告诉哥伦比亚广播公司，他们此行有一个重要的原因。他说：“在我们找到新常态的第一天过去之前，什么都不会开始，
so this was the appropriate location. Jaina's mother added, We have always had Lululemon gifts under the tree for Christmas and we decided this year was not going to be any different. Brittany was sentenced two months later on January 27, 2012 with over 200 spectators crowding the courtroom. Jaina's family spoke openly about the impact that her murder had on their lives with her brother Hugh saying, March 12, 2011 was my family's September 11, 2001. Nothing will ever be normal. Nothing will ever be the same. Jaina's brother Dirk said that he and his two sons draw pictures and we write notes and we burn them so they can rise in the smoke up to heaven. Jaina's murder had a profound impact on
所以这是合适的地点。”简娜的母亲补充说：“我们圣诞节树下总是有露露乐檬的礼物，我们决定今年也不会有任何不同。”布列塔尼在两个月后的2012年1月27日被判刑，200多名旁观者挤满了法庭。简娜的家人公开谈论了谋杀对他们生活的影响，她的兄弟休说：“2011年3月12日是我家人的2001年9月11日。一切都不会再正常了。一切都不会再一样了。”简娜的兄弟德克说，他和他的两个儿子画画、写纸条，然后把它们烧掉，这样它们就能随着烟雾升入天堂。简娜的谋杀案对
his two young boys and he told the courtroom that instead of checking the closet for boogeymen before bed, they check for Brittany Norwood. Brittany finally broke the silence that she'd maintained for the entire trial, begging for mercy and a chance of parole. In tears, she said, For the Murray family, what do I say when your daughter's gone and I'm the one convicted of her murder? I know what I say today won't take the pain away over the loss of Jaina. I hope for the Murray family someday you'll be able to find forgiveness in your heart. I am truly sorry. To illustrate the horrific nature of the assault and murder committed by Brittany,
他的两个年幼的儿子产生了深远的影响，他告诉法庭，他们睡觉前不再检查衣柜里是否有怪物，而是检查是否有布列塔尼·诺伍德。布列塔尼终于打破了她在整个审判期间保持的沉默，乞求宽恕和假释的机会。她流着泪说：“对于默里一家，当你们的女儿走了，而我是被判谋杀她的人时，我该说什么？我知道我今天说的话无法消除失去简娜的痛苦。我希望默里一家有一天能在心中找到宽恕。我真的很抱歉。”为了说明布列塔尼所犯下的袭击和谋杀的可怕性质，
an emotional judge told the courtroom that one night he went home and banged his fist against the table 300 times. This was to mimic the hand movements of Brittany as she attacked Jaina. It took him over eight minutes. He told Brittany, You mutilated this woman and with every blow you had a chance to think about what you were doing. You reveled in the gore and the lies that you told afterward were incredible. You're one hell of a liar, ma'am. Addressing the families, the judge was overcome with emotion, as he said, We don't pick our families, but frankly, if I had to pick a family, I'd want either the Norwoods or
一位情绪激动的法官告诉法庭，有一天他回家，对着桌子猛击了300次。这是为了模仿布列塔尼袭击简娜时的手部动作。这花了他八分多钟。他告诉布列塔尼：“你残害了这个女人，每一次打击你都有机会思考你在做什么。你沉溺于血腥之中，事后你说的谎言令人难以置信。你真是个了不起的骗子，女士。”在对家属讲话时，法官情绪激动，他说：“我们无法选择家人，但坦率地说，如果我必须选择一个家庭，我会选择诺伍德一家或
the Murrays. Brittany was then sentenced to life imprisonment without the possibility of parole. Jaina's family clapped and cheered as the sentence was read out. Outside of the courtroom, Jaina's father said the apology from Brittany was too little, too late, and just a last-ditch effort to have her sentence reduced. Brittany appealed her conviction on the grounds that her initial interviews with detectives should have been omitted from the trial as she hadn't been read her Miranda rights. The appeals judge dismissed this, saying that Brittany was initially interviewed as a victim, not a suspect.
默里一家。”布列塔尼随后被判处终身监禁，不得假释。当判决宣读时，简娜的家人鼓掌欢呼。法庭外，简娜的父亲说布列塔尼的道歉太少、太迟，只是为了减轻刑罚的最后挣扎。布列塔尼对判决提出上诉，理由是她与侦探的初步访谈应从审判中剔除，因为她没有被告知米兰达权利。上诉法官驳回了这一请求，称布列塔尼最初是以受害者而非嫌疑人的身份接受访谈的。
Jaina's murder continued to impact staff at the Apple Store next door, with manager Lara relocating to another store. The security guard who was on duty the night of the murder felt immensely sad about his role in the night's events. Having previously worked in rough neighborhoods, it never crossed his mind that something more than an argument between two people was happening in the yoga store. Had he been working in a more dangerous location, he would have acted on the noise. Jaina's brother Hugh was serving in the military at the time of the murder and had left Iraq to be with his family in the wake of the crime. When he returned to Iraq several weeks later,
简娜的谋杀案继续影响着隔壁苹果店的员工，经理拉拉搬到了另一家店。案发当晚值班的保安对自己在当晚事件中的角色感到无比悲伤。由于曾在治安混乱的社区工作过，他从未想过瑜伽店里发生的不仅仅是两人之间的争吵。如果他在一个更危险的地方工作，他会对噪音采取行动。简娜的兄弟休在谋杀发生时正在服兵役，在犯罪发生后离开了伊拉克与家人团聚。当他几周后回到伊拉克时，
a parcel was waiting for him. It was from Jaina who had mailed it shortly before she was killed. As detailed in the yoga store murder, Hugh opened it hesitantly, aware that it would be the final communication he would ever have with his sister. Jaina had sent him a running cap with a greeting card that listed things that didn't work on their own. Chips without dip, macaroni without cheese, me without you. Inside, she had signed off. Take care and be safe. Love you and miss you. Jaina. In the wake of Jaina's murder, a stained glass window was erected over the doorway to the main entrance of the Bethesda Lululemon store in her memory. The colorful mosaic featured the word
一个包裹在等着他。那是简娜在遇害前不久寄出的。正如《瑜伽店谋杀案》中所述，休犹豫着打开了它，意识到这将是他与妹妹最后的交流。简娜寄给他一顶跑步帽和一张贺卡，上面列出了那些单独无法发挥作用的东西：薯片没有蘸酱，通心粉没有奶酪，我没有你。在里面，她写道：“保重，注意安全。爱你，想你。简娜。”在简娜遇害后，为了纪念她，在贝塞斯达露露乐檬店主入口的门廊上方竖立了一扇彩色玻璃窗。这个彩色马赛克图案以红色草书写着“爱”字，
love emblazoned in red cursive script. It became a local landmark known throughout town as the Love Window. In December 2017, the Lululemon store relocated to another vacant lot on Bethesda Row. Unable to keep the stained glass window, Lululemon shipped it to Jaina's brother Hugh, who told NBC Washington. It means a lot to us as it represents Jaina. We definitely wanted to preserve that and have it in our home. As a means of preserving Jaina's memory and the impact she had to those who knew her, Jaina's family started the Jaina Troxel Murray Foundation. Still in existence, this foundation provides scholarships to those in financial need, with the hope that recipients will be afforded the same opportunities that Jaina had to succeed in life.
它成为了全镇闻名的地标，被称为“爱之窗”。2017年12月，露露乐檬店搬迁至贝塞斯达街区的另一个空地。由于无法保留彩色玻璃窗，露露乐檬将其运送给了简娜的兄弟休，他告诉美国全国广播公司华盛顿台：“这对我们意义重大，因为它代表了简娜。我们绝对想保留它并把它放在家里。”为了纪念简娜以及她对那些认识她的人的影响，简娜的家人成立了简娜·特罗塞尔·默里基金会。该基金会至今仍在运作，为经济困难的人提供奖学金，希望受助者能获得与简娜一样在生活中取得成功的机会。
Jaina's memory lives on in a video she posted to YouTube three months before she was murdered. In the clip, Jaina can be seen living her life to the fullest by going bungee jumping to celebrate her 30th birthday. The video is accompanied by the song Learning to Fly by Tom Petty and shows Jaina as she and her family would want her to be remembered. Full of energy, joy, and positivity. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
简娜的记忆活在她遇害前三个月发布到YouTube的一段视频中。在视频中，可以看到简娜通过蹦极来庆祝她30岁生日，尽情享受生活。视频配有汤姆·佩蒂的歌曲《学习飞行》，展示了简娜家人希望她被记住的样子：充满活力、快乐和积极。目前该剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。